one of the world's oldest travel
companies grounded along with its
aircraft in many parts of the world
including London's Gatwick Airport the
rich history of Thomas Cook unable to
save it from collapse more than 20,000
employees face redundancy the bankruptcy
is a disaster for more than 1 million
people who've booked travel with Thomas
Cook would be holidaymakers now have to
wait and try to get their money back
through various consumer protection
schemes and some of the 600,000 people
around the world on holiday are now
stranded great festivities to say the
least
annoyed well it's a problem but it's not
a problem we'll get home eventually just
got a waiting game right despite a
billion dollar injection of cash earlier
this year the company said it needed an
additional 250 million to stay afloat I
would like to say sorry to all our
customers those who are on holiday with
us now and those who have poked with us
in the coming months bringing tourists
home will be a mammoth task Britain's
Civil Aviation Authority says emergency
flights are ready to go this is the
largest repatriation since the Second
World War and we will be bringing home
everybody back back to the UK as close
as possible to their return day tens of
millions of dollars are also believed to
be owed to hotels and countries in Egypt
Turkey and Tunisia one hotel there
briefly refused to let Thomas cook
customers leave demanding money fearing
they would not get paid
Thomas Cook was rescued from near
bankruptcy eight years ago and how
people book their holidays has added to
the company's plight
my street travel shops have been facing
stiff competition from the Internet and
while package holidays like those from
Thomas Cook often provide good value
many consumers are now shopping around
online booking their accommodation and
flight separately to create a bespoke
travel experience analysts say the
companies struggle to compete and there
are accusations of mismanagement with
the company hemorrhaging money recently
Thomas Cook is a marvelous brand it has
an incredible heritage but I'm afraid in
the 21st century in the ferocious
competition of the travel industry that
counts for nothing all that matters is
do you have a profitable business and
sadly in the case of Thomas Cook we know
the answer is no a 178 year old business
steeped in history but apparently
failing to keep up with modern times
catherine Stancil al jazeera london